Aujourd'hui, je fais simple. J'ai acheté du pain demie
à la boulangerie, du jambon chez le charcutier,
des oeufs et du fromage chez le fromager.
Jefais des croque-monsieur.
Un plat, vite faitbien fait, comme on dit et bien français.
Et oui, lecroque-monsieur serait d'origine française.
Je dis bien ce serait parce que ses origines
sont unpeu trouble.
Bon certains disent que c'est pas la peine d'en faire une tartine.
Moi je dis que si.
Allez suivez-moi.
La légende raconte que lecroque monsieur aurait été inventé en 1910
par un certain Michel Lunarca,
le patron d’une brasserie parisienne nommée « Le Bel âge ».
Dans ce café, situé à deux pas de l’Opéra, les clients se pressent au comptoir
pour commander un sandwich.
De bons sandwiches fait avec de la baguette
bien fraiche du beurre et du jambon de Paris.
Merci madame !
Faut les comprendre ils ont souvent un petit creux avant ou après le spectacle.
Seulement un soir, soit parce que la commande n’avait pas été passée
soit parce que les clients étaient plus nombreux que d’habitude,
plus de baguette !
Que faire ?
Le patron aurait alors eu l’idée de remplacer la baguette par du pain de mie,
d’y glisser le jambon et le fromage
et d’enfourner le tout pour obtenir un sandwich aussi
croustillant que ceux faits avec de la baquette.
Les clients adorent et quand on lui demande
ce qu’il y a à l’intérieur il répond : de l’homme !
Du monsieur quoi !
De l’homme ? Un cannibale ? il n’a pas fait ça ?
Mais non bien sûr ! C’était une blague. Quoiqu’il en soit, le nom du nouveau plat
aurait été tout trouvé : le croque-monsieur !
Mais il y a un hic dans cette belle histoire.
On trouve des mentions du croque-monsieur
au moins 20 ans plus tôt,
dans une revue datant de 1891 ou encore dans un journal de 1896.
La seule différence avec la recette du patron du Bel âge c’est que les croque-monsieur sont sautés à la poêle et non cuits au four.
L’innovation de Michel Lunarca a peut-être consisté
à réinventer sa cuisson
Oula ! L’heure tourne, je commence à avoir une petite faim.
Allez, direction la cuisine !
Pour faire un bon croque-monsieur, il faut deux tranches de pain de mie,
ce pain qui se caractérise par sa croûte et sa mie moelleuse.
l ressemble au pain que l’on consommait au XVIIe siècle à la cour de
Marie de Médicis et qu’on appelait « le pain à la reine ».
Hm, mamie.
Même si pour être tout à fait exact, l’invention du pain de mie tel que nous le connaissons aujourd’hui revient aux anglais.
Ce sont eux qui en 1800 ont inventé le moule en étain dans lequel il est cuit
et qui lui donne sa forme si particulière.
Mais revenons à notre croque-monsieur.
T'as oublié la béchamel ! C'est bon avec la béchamel !
C’est vrai ! On peut aussi ajouter de la béchamel.
Vous savez, cette sauce blanche préparée à partir d’un roux,
qui est obtenu en faisant fondre du beurre mélangé à de la
farine qu'on allonge ensuite avec du laitou de la crème fraîche.
On dit que c’est une sauce mère parce qu’elle est utilisée
dans beaucoup de recette et elle sert aussi de base à d’autres sauces.
Alors dans le cas du croque-monsieur,
on glisse cette béchamel entre le fromage râpé etle jambon
et on recouvre la tranche de pain demie supérieure
avec un mélange de béchamel et defromage râpé.
Pour le coup, c’est mieux de le passer au four.
D’ailleurs il existe peut-être d’autres recettes.
N’hésitez pas à me les communiquer dans les commentaires de cette vidéo.
Le temps que ça cuisse, retournons à l'atelier.
Le croque-monsieur est tellement célèbre, qu’il est à la carte
de presque toutes les brasseries de France.
Même à la maison, mais là c'est gratos.
Il a aussi voyagé un peu partout à travers le monde.
Il y conserve d’ailleurs la plupart du temps son nom d’origine.
Pour le célébrer comme il se doit, un restaurant strasbourgeois a lancé
le 19 avril 2020 la première journée mondiale du croque-monsieur.
Bon, il faudra voir si l’initiative conquiert le monde dans les prochaines années comme l’a fait le croque lui-même
Et ce n’est pas la seule chose qu’ils ont faite les strasbourgeois.
Effectivement. Une équipe du restaurant Croque Bedaine à Strasbourg s’est même lancé le défi de confectionner le plus grand croque-monsieur du monde.
Un record jusqu’alors détenu par les américains.
Ils ont assemblé 300 tranches de pain de mie sur une surface de près de 10m2 qu’ils ont recouvert de 40 litres de béchamel, 50 kilos d’emmental et de 6O kg de jambon.
Et comme il n’y avait pas de four suffisamment grand,
vous ne devinerez jamais avec quoi ils l'ontchauffé ...
... un fer à repasser !
Ça n'a pas fait un plie, il était excellent.
Oups ! Mes croque-monsieur, ils sont prêts !
Pas mal hein ! Mais ça manque unpeu de couleurs.
Je sais je vais ajouter un œuf !
Du coup ce ne sera plus un croque-monsieur
mais un croque-madame.
On l’appelle comme ça parce que, selon la légende toujours,
l'œuf au plat a la forme d’un chapeau de dames.
On le nomme aussi croque-à-cheval
puisque l’œuf est posé à cheval sur le sandwich.
Allez, avec une bonne salade on va se régaler.
Tiens savez vous que même Marcel Proust a écrit sur le croque Monsieur.
Oui oui Marcel Proust l’écrivain, l’auteur de « à la recherche du temps perdu ».
Il s’agit d’une œuvre composés de 7 parties, 7 livres si vous préférez.
Il y fait allusion dans « A l’ombre des jeunes filles en fleur ».
Ce deuxième volet est consacré à son adolescence
et en particulier ses sentiments pour une certaines Gilberte Swann.
En clair, Marcel est amoureux de Gilberte sauf qu'à un moment
il doit partir au bord de la mer.
Bref, ça finit par plus coller entre eux.
Ça arrive, pas de quoi en faire un plat.
Lui en fait un livre, un beau pavé, pas trop saignant.
Mais si on prend son temps ça se digère facilement, je vous lis un extrait ? Allez.
Or, en sortant du concert, comme, en reprenant le chemin qui va vers l'hôtel,
nous nous étions arrêtés un instant sur la digue,
ma grand-mère et moi, pour échanger quelques mots avec
Mme de Villeparisis qui nous annonçait
qu'elle avait commandé pour nous à l'hôtel
des « croque-monsieur » et des oeufs à la crème.
Vous voyez c’est mignon à croquer.
Allez, à très bientôt pour une nouveau "Sur la planche"
et puis si cette vidéo vous inspire des questions.
N'hésitez pas à les poser sur les réseauxdes Épicurieux
en commentaires des vidéos et enutilisant
le hashtag #DisJamy.
J'y réponds tout les jours dans "CJamy"
sur france 5 à 17 heures.
À très vite !
Bonne lecture et bon appétit.